bonsoir nous sommes le mardi 23 février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour
retour sur votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités également des
journalistes de la rédaction
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres de cette édition le quartier de
la boissière sous les eaux à plaisir une
rupture de canalisation a inondé les
terrains du stade des peupliers ainsi
que plusieurs habitants reportage à
suivre
le secours populaire donne la chance aux
enfants qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de partir en vacances de se
rendre aux sports d'hiver
plusieurs anciens événements vont
profiter pendant ses vacances comme
fatoumata une petite clé sienne de séton
nous l'avons suivi avant son départ et
ir vous avez découvert l'histoire du
site de météo france a traversé de son
fondateur aujourd'hui dans un second
épisode nous vous proposons de revenir
sur l'évolution technologique les
prévisions du centre qui fête ses 120
ans cette année et je vous le disais en
titre à plaisir le quartier de la
boissière a été totalement submergé par
les eaux vendredi dernier suite à une
rupture de canalisation des terrains du
stade des peupliers et plusieurs
habitations ont été touchées
comme l'expliquent michael almy toro et
mélanie poté lola vous rentrez également
dans le monde j'avais toujours par bach
derrière christophe rosso est l'une des
victimes de l'inondation du quartier de
la boissière à plaisir ce vendredi vers
7 heures du matin une rupture de
canalisation de 60 cm de diamètre à
proximité de l'école alain fournier à
entrer une submersion partielle du
secteur
l'incident a entraîné des dégâts chez
habitants au niveau du jardin on a été
inondée surtout que la partie du jardin
la terrasse a commencé à être inondées
également c'est surtout surtout le coin
détente qui a eu qui a eu pas mal de
dégâts jacuzzi qui est maintenant hors
service le coin cuisine extérieure qui
est hors service aussi plusieurs
milliers de mètres cubes d'eau se sont
également déversé sur le stade des
peupliers les terrains rénové en 2012
pour un coût de 2 millions d'euros ont
été fortement endommagés les terrains
synthétiques sont je dirais en a
sèchement puisqu'on attend de voir
comment les choses se passent tout de
suite on a imaginé qu'ils puissent ne
pas être du tout utilisable par les
sportifs d'ailleurs nous avons fait l
arrêté pour qu'il ne soit pas utilisable
on va attendre que ça sèche un peu puis
on verra ce qu'il en est mais j'ai bien
peur qu'il faille les remettre en état
complètement une décision concernant la
rénovation déteint sur un prise d'ici
trois semaines par la mairie les
rencontres sportives sont pour le moment
reporter et vous savez les vacances ont
commencé pour les enfants de la zone
s'est pourtant chaque année en france
près de 3 millions d'enfants n'ont pas
la chance de justement partir en
vacances avec copains de vacances le
secours populaire aidé les enfants de
familles défavorisées à sortir de leur
quartier
trois enfants yves et noir ont pris la
direction des pistes de ski des hautes
pyrénées cette semaine c'est le cas de
fatoumata elle a 7 ans elle habite les
clayes-sous-bois fanny bourdillon l'a
suivi avant son départ regarder les
vacances un droit pour tous et tout au
long de l'année
c'est le credo du secours populaire aux
clayes-sous-bois fatoumata sept ans
s'apprête à partir pour la première fois
aux sports d'hiver
alors au moment de faire la valise le
choix est difficile
un put en face il parle par exemple de
la neige et s'assit effet un peu beau je
suis plus content mais savent que
j'avais que ça se passe bien on voit et
pato blessé
et devenir sauce cas c'est un truc
la petite fille est déjà parti en
vacances cet été avec le secours
populaire
le billet de train est à la charge de
l'association et le reste du séjour à la
famille d'accueil pour sarhane sa maman
ses vacances loin des clayes-sous-bois
permettent un moment d'évasion mais
aussi de la responsabiliser quand elles
viennent
elle révèle lui s'est elle fait elle
fait tout tout seul avant ça elle peut
pas faire ça moi aide pas à bormes samoa
vraiment très près l'opération copains
des vacances donne surtout la chance aux
enfants des familles défavorisées de se
faire de nouveaux amis
les bénévoles dont qui sont les premiers
à voir les enfants et elle elle est
ramenée au treasure retour donc je me
disent qu'à chaque fois les enfants sont
ravis qu'ils ont pu faire des activités
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas forcément faire
chez eux à la maison on a également des
enfants qui ne veulent pas repartir qui
fait rester dans la famille d'accueil
8h27 direction de tarbes ce lundi matin
pour fatou matin à la gare montparnasse
la séparation avec sa maman est
difficile mais dans dix jours elle
reviendra avec des souvenirs plein la
tête rattrapent les copies
eh bien les vacances et je me suis bien
amusé
l'été dernier quarante enfants yvelinois
ont pu profiter de l'opération copains
des vacances du secours populaire et
nous restons présents dans le milieu
associatif avec frère d'agir une
association et l'on courtoise qui vient
en aide aux démunis aux personnes dans
le besoin pour nous en parler en plateau
malik loi celle bonsoir vous êtes le
président de l'association et femmes
hasnaoui bonsoir à vous également vous
êtes bénévole justement au sein de
l'association
alors l'association frères d'argile
mahdi qui a été créée il ya dix mois sur
votre initiative
tu pouvais me raconter un peu quand ça
s'est passé comment vous avez justement
cette idée cette volonté de créer
l'association ce ce déclic on va dire ça
ça fait un peu c'était un peu nécessaire
je pense vu le nombre de migrants qui
arrivent et c'est dans cette année en
fait sur paris maintenant on est
essentiellement basé vraiment on
s'occupe vraiment de la région
parisienne et on a trouvé qu'ils ont de
vraiment faire quelque chose parce que
ça les besoins grandissent et quoi
comparer à vraiment comme moi j'étais
jeune on n'avait pas tout ça n'avait pas
tout ça on voyait pas autant
d'associations maintenant c'est quelque
chose qui se fait de plus en plus dans
les banlieues donc ça vraiment on en est
fier et donc c'est un boulot qui se fait
petit à petit c'est vraiment comme
fonder une société c'est un truc qui en
peu de temps mais on est bien épaulé m'a
beaucoup de soutien et ça avance petit à
petit vous avez décidé de rejoindre
l'association
j'attends sa création ne sais pas après
ça s'est un petit peu après je suis un
peu parti du cercle d'amis de malick et
ils m'ont a dit simon a parlé du coup
j'ai décidé de rejoindre l'association
alors qu'elles sont un petit peu les
missions de l'association pratiquement
comment ça se passe comment vous
organisez donc on fait une b2
distribution voire trois par semaine
donc c'est simple ça se répète c'est
répétitif on est on est un peu cadré sur
ça
on a nos bénévoles et préparatrice on a
beaucoup de partenaires restauration
deux boulangeries atteindre pas mal de
donc tout le monde tourne un peu dans
notre sens pour cette cause chose
importante
donc on se prépare on à la semaine pour
préparer la distribution du week end
si on va distribuer vraiment pour
préciser donc des kits que soient les
styles vestimentaires hygiène voilà
surtout le contact avec les laissent des
empreintes des sans-abri y'a pas que les
sans abri il ya aussi ceux qui sont
vraiment loger mais un peu délaissé une
fois qu'ils sont une fois qu'ils sont
logés ils sont plus prioritaires par
rapport aux attentes sociales ou donc
vraiment appris à travailler quand même
à faire derrière folle et si froid vous
venez par exemple dans les hôtels où
certains sont relogés dans les centres
d'accueil pour vraiment et justement le
la collecte de tout ce qui est ces kits
vestimentaire ça se fait les gens sont
plutôt donne assez facilement
comment ça se passe un petit peu c'est
au niveau des vêtements on était bordée
par exemple mais on croit encore sa part
ça vient et sinon on fait des récoltes
aussi on travaille beaucoup aussi et je
tiens à remercier vraiment toutes les
associations qui nous qui nous aident en
soit on fait beaucoup d'intérêt sauce on
est en train de fonder des belles choses
avec ce sont de toute l'île de france
donc c'est ça va beaucoup plus vite fait
et sinon des dons c'est un peu au bon
vouloir des gens on a commencé vraiment
entre nous on était cinq on mettait des
20 euros chacun et on allait faire des
courses et 11 et des sacs de méreau pas
qu'on allait distribuer ça a commencé
comme ça vraiment ensuite ça s'est
développé
maintenant on a un compte bancaire en a
plein de choses donc ça devient un peu
on a des belles surprises on reçoit des
dons conséquents et des fois vous faites
aussi à vous aller distribuer justement
ces kits comment ça se passe avec les
gens et sont plutôt bien accueillies
enfin ils accueillent plutôt bien va
trouver votre initiative invite à furnes
on a littéralement un petit un petit
comité qui nous reçoit qui nous calcul
de nous voir qui est contents de nous
voir et franchement ça fait vraiment
très plaisir que qu'on ait ce retour là
justement vous vous créez des liens
justement avec sa personne que vous
voyez toute la semaine
oui oui on est très content de les voir
ils sont très contents de nous voir ils
nous voient ils nous appellent à frère
david
du coup il ça fait vraiment plaisir
c'est ce et voilà c'est très bien alors
justement frères d'argile ce mois ci
dans ça vous avez aussi des valeurs que
vous voulez aussi au portier bolli
explique un petit peu justement d'où
vient ce nom et aussi vos valeurs
également donc nous vraiment des valeurs
qui correspondent à cette idée c'est
vraiment de s'occuper des personnes qu
importe la religion leur couleur leur
sexe leur âge n'importe
on est vraiment en fait selon nos
croyances après sa re surgi dans le
comportement
c'est vraiment de s'occuper de pas faire
attention aux différences
donc on descend tous en présence de
dents
donc de là on part de l'idée que l'on
doit s'occuper bientôt on allait devoir
envers les autres peu importe qu'il soit
peu importe on doit vraiment s'occuper
tout le monde alors il ya un volet
également un social que vous développez
plus vraiment dans la ville d'elancourt
d'un bien avec les jeunes sont acteurs
sociaux font de chasse est en train de
se mettre en place avec la mairie
d'elancourt prochainement j'imagine
j'espère que ça va aboutir
donc on est en train de voir ça avec le
service jeunesse pour
j'espère notre côté on a commencé déjà à
100 notre initiative c'est de sortir
d'essayer de sortir un peu les jeunes de
leur quartier de leur banc alors
proposer d'autres choses c'est des
choses qui ne vont pas pensé à faire
donc vraiment leur montre ce côté même
des plus jeunes vraiment mon petit frère
ma petite soeur les ans voir qu'ils sont
cons tout le monde ça leur montre
vraiment le la chance qu'ils ont déjà
et ça ça réveille des choses en nous en
fait c'est difficile à expliquer mais ça
arrive et on se rend compte des choses
ça à votre que c'est plus facile
peut-être quand on est jeune aussi parce
que c'est vrai que vous êtes jeunes tous
les deux justement de lien à contacter
et de faire avancer ça vous est
peut-être mieux reçus ouais
effectivement après je pense pas que le
fait qu'on soit jeune ça affecte au fait
que les gens reçoivent mais lewis avait
donné souriant on est sociable et ça
passe très bien
parce que justement voilà donc
l'association a été créée il ya 15 mois
à peu près vous avez dédié à cinq mois
maintenant il a de plus en plus de
bénévoles il ya aussi des projets de
développement
comment vous avez vu grandir ça parce
que c'est vrai que l'on vous voit la
montée n'associons ça demande beaucoup
de travail et finalement tout va très
vite quand vous avez vous êtes organisé
un peu à ce sujet ben justement on a la
chance d'avoir un président qui s'occupe
de pas mal de choses et c'est vrai que
on essaie de gérer comme on peut mais on
y arrive très bien avec tout ce qui se
passe et on nous aident beaucoup aussi
donc voilà c'est super c'est une
aventure qui qui fait que commencer et
on a hâte de voir la suite quoi
justement donc un cession va se
développer à une antenne qui va être
créée
dans le 91 et on a l'intention de créer
des points relais un peu partout tant
qu'on pourra tant qu aura des
volontaires on est prêt à accueillir
tout le monde
il n'y a pas d'âge n'y a pas de couleur
rien donc venez tous
le plus jeune a 18 17 ans même à un
mineur enfin sans compter les petits
vraiment des enfants mais pendant le
bénévole de plus jeune 17 ans la plus
âgée à la 38 ans et voilà on n'y a
aucune différence entre nous on s'entend
super bien et tout se passe à la maison
c'est le qg un peu de la sauce vous avez
des projets sur versailles plus dans les
yvelines watts et à l'emploi voilà on
essaye vraiment de d'optimiser en fait
tout tout tout nos actions sûr notamment
sur versailles parce que ce serait
beaucoup plus simple plus pratique et on
se rend compte qu'il ya un besoin aussi
là bas on peut pas passer à côté aller
se balader sur paris pour y distribuer
les 6 à versailles on passe devant
donc on est en train de voir ça avec la
mairie on essaye de faire les démarches
alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir un grand
événement ou initiative prochainement et
qui va être organisé auquel en plus à
joindre
écoutez ça se passe tous les samedis
dimanches
dimanche matin un dimanche midi c'est
plutôt le week-end donc vraiment suite à
des nocturnes aussi dans la semaine ça
c'est vraiment le quotidien des
distributions alimentaires
vestimentaires et gêne aussi sinon on
est sur certains projets vous pouvez
aussi aller voir sur la page facebook et
d'argile et donc l'avenir et toutes les
informations mais sinon ça prendrait un
peu de temps pour expliquer vraiment de
projet de pas mal de projets alors
justement voilà si vous êtes intéressé
si vous voulez rejoindre l'association
frères d'argile les informations
s'affichent en bas de votre écran il ya
une adresse internet également page
facebook où vous retrouvez toutes les
informations en tout cas merci beaucoup
à vous d'être venus si toi répondu à
notre question tout autre sujet à
présent nous allons parler météo hier
vous avez découvert l'histoire du site
de météo france
attrape à travers celle de son fondateur
les hontes et seringues de bord devenu
propriété publique le centre
météorologique qui fête ses 120 ans
cette année est toujours en activité
une dizaine de personnes travaillent
dans le service prévisionnelle avec des
technologies toujours plus avancé le
point sur ces évolutions avec mélanie
poker
du météo grave de terrain de bord à la
sonde semi-automatique 120 ans
d'histoire en météorologiques
general de son c'était quelque chose de
très simple qui était très gros aussi
qui faisait à peu près 4 kg qui était
grand comme ça qu'on a envoyés jusqu'à 2
km accroché un ballon au départ sa
mesure est que la température
après progressivement on a rajouté la
prise de mesure de la pression en même
temps dessus et on est arrivé à la
première radio sonde le site de trappes
conserve aujourd'hui encore les vieilles
sonde l'une des plus anciennes est
pourtant toujours d'actualité celle
utilisée lors de l'année polaire de 1932
imaginé et créé par jules richard
industriels français les sondes
deviennent plus compact et plus
sophistiquées
c'est aussi le cas des ballons si on
regarde par exemple testing de bord avec
ses ballons qui était très gros qu'ils
aient 26 mètres cubes
il y a 5 % ces ballons qui ont dépassé
les 20 kilomètres d'altitude alors que
ensuite avec ce qu'on a utilisées
progressivement avec la miniaturisation
des radios sont on arrive maintenant un
résultat où on a quasiment 100% des
ballons qui dépasse les 25 km il y
aurait beaucoup qui arrive à 30 km
d'altitude et ça avec deux mètres cubes
maximum de gaza utilisé depuis quelques
mois l'envoi de ballon est devenu
semi-automatique toujours préparé par
l'âme les sondes sont aujourd'hui
envoyées automatiquement
elles ont une vitesse constante de 300
mètres par minute en évaluant
température pression humidité ainsi que
la vitesse et la direction du vent elle
les capteurs doivent atteindre au
minimum 20 kilomètres d'altitude et
c'est dans cette salle que les données
sont réceptionnés avant d'être analysée
par les prévisionnistes pendant en gros
une heure 45 à 2 heures elle va
continuer tout au cours de sa montée
elle va faire des mesures de température
de pression d'humidité qu'on peut voir
en direct sur l'écran du sondage qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure avec en rouge des
courbes d'humidité et en blanc la courbe
de température de ballons avec la
pression qui vit du a va augmenter de
volume jusqu'à jusqu'au moment où il va
éclater pour l'année 2016 année
bissextile 732 ballons sondes seront
envoyées ils continueront ainsi à faire
la pluie et le beau temps ou du moins
de le prévoir et cette semaine c'est
william el est qui nous rejoint en
plateau pour une chronique santé où il y
avait le bon soir vous êtes intéressé
aux médecines alternatives bonsoir oui
on les appelle médecine non
conventionnelle ou parallèle les
médecines alternatives désigne une
grande variété de traitements non
reconnues par la profession médicale
alors ce n'est pas parce que sont pas
reconnu qu'elle ne fonctionne pas pour
vous donner un exemple j'en ai choisi
trois florane est ce que vous connaissez
la thérapie par le rire
alors j'en ai un petit peu entendu
parler mais je ne suis pas trop très
bien alors vous savez peut-être déjà que
rire une dizaine de minutes par jour
prolonger l'espérance de vie alors selon
marie thérèse rose qui a animé un
atelier sur cette pratique
c'est tout à fait le cas alors quand on
regarde les images comme ça ça peut
peut-être faire un peu peur ou ça peut
paraître étrange mais ça leur fait
revenu ça leur fait du bien et ça leur
apporte même un peu plus pleurer rire a
aussi un effet sur la douleur c'est à
dire qu étant donné qu'ils
produit des andonces il donc ils sont
proches de la morphine le ring
effectivement atténuer la douleur
surtout pour les personnes âgées on
parle beaucoup il faut faire attention à
ceux ci à cela leur alimentation elle
reste on parle jamais de plaisir aux ci
aurait envie lui on n'a pas besoin de
prendre des médicaments
alors bien sûr florane pas besoin d'être
vieux pourrir ses ateliers et exercices
sont accessibles à tous et vire peut
même vous faire économiser quelques
séances de massage y aurait reproduit
des tas de substance et de
neurotransmetteurs et d'euphorisants qui
permettent effectivement de lutter
contre le stress mais pas que ça ça peut
permettre aussi d'avoir une meuf une
meilleure digestion
parce que quand vous riez par exemple
c'est un exemple vos côtés le bouge donc
elle fait une sorte de massage sur
l'estomac et l'intestin et le foie donc
ça fait des organes qui vaut mieux
fonctionner bienvenue dans leurs aires a
beaucoup plus de bien sa compétence oui
tout à fait j'en connais un autre qui
s'occupe de vos biens fait de votre
digestion et de vos organes
il s'appelle david baconnais il essono
thérapeute alors c'est pas une maladie
mais bien une forme de médecine mais
écoutez le il vous expliquera mieux - de
manière simple c'est utiliser les fonds
pour équilibrer de la circulation
d'énergie dans le corps c'est une
technique qui aident à retrouver un
équilibre pour une meilleure santé
morale et meilleure santé physique
vous allez me dire concrètement comment
ça marche david utilise des sons pour
apaiser vos organes mais pas n'importe
quel son vous le voyez sur ces images il
utilise les ce qu'on appelle des bols
tibétains ou des bols chantants mais
aussi des diapasons
on va travailler sur des choses beaucoup
plus psychologique je disais le stress
sur le deuil qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
d'une personne sur et des ados des
enfants qui sont enfouis scolaire voilà
ça on va travailler peut être plus avec
les bonnes ou avec le reiki du son et
quand c'est plus physique entre alliés
plus avec les diapason
musicien qui a mis en place cette
technique des diapasons qui fait bien
maman a trouvé une note pour chaque
d'apaisant donc de même façon on a mis
en vibration et on va le poser sur la
main sur le point qui est intéressant
pour la personne
alors pour résumer les diapason pour le
physique et les bols pour le
psychologique
je me pose des questions sur la dernière
pratique aux elle nous présente et
william ne vous inquiétez pas et celle
là vous la connaissez forcément elle est
de plus en plus en vogue de nos jours je
veux parler de l'hypnose alors pas geek
nos spectacles comme on entend parler à
la télé mais d'hypnos thérapeutique
pratiqué en cabinet et même dans
certains hôpitaux
j'ai rencontré marie l'intérêt
sophrologue qui pratique l'hypnose heil
en cours et qui m'a expliqué cette
méthode
en fait l'idée l'hypnose c'est
d'installer la personne dans un état de
détente un état de relaxation ce qu'on
appelle un état de conscience modifiée
et c'est dans cet état de conscience
modifiée que la personne que la fin
l'inconscient de la personne est le plus
sensible réceptif à tous qu'il va
pouvoir lui être dit et notamment on va
parler de suggestions donc c'est là où
le l'inconscient est plus réceptif aux
idées suggestions qu'on va pouvoir le
faire
c'est un petit côté une section comme la
fille manon oui tout à fait mais là on
n'est pas au cinéma alors si vous
comptez faire tomber amoureux de vous
l'homme de vos rêves ou alors suggérer à
votre patron l'idée de vous augmentez ça
ne marchera pas il faut d'abord être
réceptif à l'hypnose est pour ca marilyn
discute avec son patient avant en lui
demandant ce qu'il veut ces attentes
comme par exemple arrêter de fumer ou
des insomnies concernant arrêter de
fumer marie villemin confié qu'il y
avait de plus en plus de personnes qui
venaient la voir avec cet objectif
eh bien ça donne des idées pour
certaines personnes de la rédaction
pourquoi pas merci beaucoup williams
nouveau retrouver très prochainement
pour une nouvelle chronique et on reste
dans la santé justement avec vous alors
les aidants familiaux
ce sont ces personnes qui soutiennent
une proches victimes de handicap ou de
maladies qui sont souvent trop seul face
à cette lourde tâche qui les uns qu'on
depuis juin 2013
l'association gérondi cap de montigny le
bretonneux a lancé un programme de
soutien aux aidants avec l'organisation
de réunions d'ateliers thématiques et
même de groupes de paroles vouliez hamel
justement et fanny bourdillon se sont
rendus à une de ces à l'une de ses
réunions pardon qui avait pour thème
pour thème l'aromathérapie
lis tu d isolement voilà à quoi sont
confrontés les aidants familiaux tous
les jours aujourd'hui réunies dans un
entrée dans café organisée par
l'association gérondi cap ils reçoivent
conseils et informations sur différentes
techniques pouvant les aider dans leurs
problématiques quotidiennes
aujourd'hui découverte de
l'aromathérapie l'aromathérapie c'est
l'utilisation de du l'essentiel d'huile
végétale de produits 100% naturels
là on était sur un format échanges
plutôt découvrir ce que les gens savent
comment il travaille avec réajuster
parce qu'on a vu qu'il ya un monsieur
qui avait mis pas mal de 'brut' sur un
mouchoir et puis l'on il ya eu des
réactions au niveau de la peau donc
c'est plutôt donné une pratique sage et
prudente et sérieuse rendez vous pour
les aidants qui fait partie d'un projet
en particulier à toutes les pratiques et
groupes de paroles sont également
organisées tous les ans ça apporte
plusieurs choses déjà de l'information
ça leur permet de se retrouver dans la
pluralité des aides qui sont proposés ça
leur permet de mieux s'y retrouver de
mieux orienter leur leurs besoins et de
savoir à qui s'adresser dans leur
situation pour moi c'est l'occasion
d'une part de rencontrer des gens
d'autres personnes parce que je vis seul
et d'autre part c'est aussi l'occasion
de d'enrichir ses connaissances un
programme qui existe depuis 2013 et qui
permet surtout de tisser un lien social
en échangeant sur les difficultés
d'assister et d'aider un proche dans
tous les instants de la vie et on
termine à ce journal par du sport la
première édition du trail des villes
royales étaient programmés ce dimanche
les coureurs se sont élancés de la pièce
d'eau des suisses de versailles en
direction du château de rambouillet plus
de mille courageux ont participé à ces
51 km les détails avec michael et demi
d'euros qui pour l'occasion a chaussé
ses plus belles d'assiette un parcours
de 51 km sur des sentiers de randonnée
entre château de versailles le château
de rambouillet le tracé a été imaginé
par les organisateurs du premier trail
des villes royales un programme inédit
dans les yvelines ont voulu organiser
une course qui était longue
qui était en ile-de-france en hiver
alors qu'il n'y en a pas encore et
l'idée de promouvoir un petit peu le
tourisme le patrimoine de la région
entre le château de versailles château
de rambouillet est venue il ya neuf mois
et neuf mois après comme un accouchement
on est haut sur la ligne de départ
les sportifs avaient la possibilité de
couvrir l'intégralité de la course seul
ou en équipe de 3 avec un passage de
témoin chevreuse et auffargis c'est à la
mode maintenant il y en a beaucoup donc
il faut savoir trouver savoir être
original pour pour attirer du monde
il trouve que c'est très original pour
cette grande première plus de 1000
coureurs venus des yvelines de la région
ile de france de suisse et de belgique
ont mis leurs baskets pour participer à
ce rendez vous nous sommes venus en
équipe nous avons quatre les ministres
lait voilà et on va essayer de se
comment dire elle de se donner un petit
peu le un petit peu de se tirer la
bourre girerd
on fera pas de podium c'est surtout le
fait une sortie comme on dirait le
sortie jean sortie d'entraînement où on
sera de donner un petit peu quand même
au niveau des résultats nicolas du hay a
terminé la course individuelle en 3h47
dans la catégorie relais la team pdm a
bouclé le périple en 3 heures 49
une deuxième édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine et c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de nous avoir
suivis tout de suite vous retrouvez
nouradine un bon pour le 7-8 société
objet du débat la radicalisation quelles
réponses pour y faire face c'est la fin
de cette saison jouer déjà dit quand à
moi je vous retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition de 7,8 le journal je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée